so avlock is uh the CEO of Angelus many
of you have probably heard of Angelus
before
um you all help companies in a variety
of different ways but I thought a great
place to start is rather than how you
all help other companies talk about
Angelus itself one of the things I've
noticed from the outside is how fast you
guys ship product and it seems like
there's almost Rogue employees
internally who kind of see a problem go
write some code and like on the way out
the door they're like hey by the way
this is getting published right talk
about where's that culture of shipping
fast and kind of just a bias for Action
come from yeah and can everyone hear me
yeah we're good
um yeah it's funny you say Rogue
employees I mean the number of debates
uh that we have internally is uh quite
High
um I would say the the culture of
shipping just comes from a pure founder
mentality I mean the entire existence
evangelist is uh to make sure that we're
here to serve the founder and that
bleeds into everything we do all the
products we pursue
um the way we build teams uh and at the
very beginning or the at the top of it
it starts with engineers and designers
at the top of totem pole so culturally
they're at the very top and then when we
think about
um uh resourcing projects products it's
typically a very small team with a
single leader that's typically an
engineer or a designer so it's actually
pretty rare that it's a product manager
we do have that for exceptions but
typically it's an engineer or designer
that leads and then it's just an insane
sense of urgency just to push push push
because
um when you think about a technology
company the entire purpose of it is to
grow and to serve your mission and
typically your first product if your
Google will become massive and you can
just uh basically continue to scale off
of that but for most companies you'll
build one product but then they have to
be a multi-product company and the thing
about being a multi-product company is
you can't skip steps just because one
product reaches scale doesn't mean that
the second product the third product
that you build is going to naturally
rescale so you're gonna have a zero to
one moment multiple times in a company
and so the only way to do that is to
make sure you have a team that's tightly
aligned that understands how to launch
new products also how to just take
failure right like it's not that every
product we launch succeeds but you can't
skip steps so for us we have a sole
focus on being a multi-product company
and making sure that we're taking enough
at bats to build a uh enduring company
now one of the key themes across many
businesses so Amazon jetbasis would say
uh never have a meeting where two pizzas
can't cover it if you read the book The
Outsiders they talk a lot about
decentralization and kind of pushing
decision making as far down in the
organization as possible hearing you
talk about the setup of Angel is how do
you make sure that you continue to
create a culture of uh speed right so so
there's a biasive action and kind of
shipping and you're doing that by
pushing some decision making down but
what about motivating employees
especially when we have remote work now
we have you know kind of all of these
things that could serve as distractions
how do you keep people kind of on edge
and really wanting to build these
products yeah honestly it just starts
top down in terms of applying a strong
sense of urgency and making sure that
folks understand that look if you're
going to naturally default in next week
two weeks from now why not tomorrow why
not uh you know the day after that I
really pulled out from Frank sudman and
actually now I'm also reading new launch
biography so if if you all haven't
picked it up definitely pick it up uh
you you'll uh
put it this way my sense of urgency is
going to increase after reading that
biography
um but it starts at the top you have to
set the pace you have to set the tempo
and then you have to expect folks are
going to rise to that Tempo and then you
have to have other folks in the company
that would be the culture of carriers
that are going to call out when we're
not being as fast as we could be uh it's
interesting you bring up the remote and
in person
um I think it's really hard to do this
remote you have to have folks coming in
person I don't know if five days a week
is gonna be the new Norm or two days a
week it really depends on the company
but for Angelus we are coming back in
the office and we are uh there because
you have to build that in-person
collaboration or if you are already
remote one of the things that could be
useful is just fly somewhere uh just jam
on a product launch and just don't
leave the place until it's out
there so again it starts at the top you
got to set the tempo you got to bring
people together uh and you just gotta
push push push push and will be
uncomfortable because it's
um the default for most people and the
default for any group of humans is
slowness it's um uh it's um yeah let's
take another few weeks to get it right
get it perfect but in reality you just
have to push hard and you have to treat
urgency as a core principle in the
company I want to talk about some
tactical things that startups faces
problems in some of these cases you guys
have built products because you solved
the problem in the market and said hey
we need to go solve this for Founders
one of them which is somewhat nuanced
but actually is a huge uh almost
pandemic in startups is that cap tables
are almost always wrong yeah and talk a
little bit about why the cap tables are
wrong and how you guys thought about we
can just solve this with software and
kind of provide a solution yeah it's
super interesting actually
um so if you think about cap tables
about a decade ago uh cap tables were
all managed in spreadsheets right
um and you would effectively update the
cap table uh every financing round like
the lawyers would manage it and the big
innovation back then was okay let's
stick it from spreadsheets and let's
move it online
um but since then there's been zero
innovation in cap tables and the issues
that we saw uh with cap tables was that
you'd have capitals that would just be
completely wrong so what happens is
between a financing round and the next
financing round uh a bunch of Agreements
are made you hire employees you may
bring on advisors and then when it's
recorded in the cap table it departs
from the underlying legal docs and when
it departs from underlying legal docs
it's now a
um it's just a thing that lawyers do in
the next financing round called tie-ups
you just tie everything out I mean
Angelus went through it herself recently
where it was last year tied out our
legal docs to the cap table make sure
everything's updated but the root of the
problem is that capitals are just hard
to use you talk to any founder today
none of them use it even the most
experienced Founders do not touch it I
have a close friend who's I think a
third time founder pretty sophisticated
just like I literally can't touch
capable software because I'm worried I'm
going to mess something up so what does
he do pays for the subscription and pays
for a lawyer who goes and manages it and
so the root issue that we saw was people
like Founders can't use the cap table as
what we think of as currency right you
think about cash you raise cash you pay
people in cash and they can do great
work but when it comes to equity it's
really hard to use equity in the same
way now to be clear I'm not saying go
out and get Equity to everyone right but
it's an irreversible decision you want
to manage your Capital well but if you
can make it easy to manage the cap table
like almost as simple as setting a venmo
transaction uh so the founder can use it
they meet uh they meet someone who can
help them with a customer introduction
to meet someone who can help them with a
hire they should be able to just send
that equity and know that it's correct
and everything is perfect and that's
actually if you look at the set of
Innovations we've had around cap tables
our UVS we've had Equity blocks even we
just launched a co-pilot in cap table so
you can actually talk to it and you can
say hey Grant x amount of equity to this
person and everything is managed
perfectly it's coming from that place of
put it back in the hands of Founders two
of ageless executive hires actually came
from uh me pinpointing someone who I
thought can help with that hire I gave
them equity and they made amazing
referrals and they actually one of them
became our CFO the other one became our
head of design and head of marketing uh
that actually changed the trajectory of
the company so again I I think
um a really great Equity Capital
solution can give a superpower to the
founders and it just doesn't exist today
it's just completely broken
let's talk fundraising um obviously
Angelus is known for helping companies
fundraise a lot of investors also look
for access to startups via Angelus talk
what you're seeing in the environment
today given that interest rates are high
you know Tech funding is slowed but then
also how maybe people are using the
product differently ruvs maybe you can
explain what that is and kind of are you
seeing smaller checks and people
rounding up rounds or institutional
investors still coming in just talk a
little over here yeah so when it comes
to fundraising every time I talk to a
Founder I try to Anchor them back in
2019 and 2020 not 2021 and 2022. so when
you actually uh just have amnesia okay
for the past couple of years and you
just anchor back on 2019 and 2020. what
you'll see is that
um precede just pre uh so precede median
valuation and preseason evaluation today
so 2019 and today actually is up uh same
thing with seed it's up series a is like
slightly up and series B is flat and
seriously is flat uh and so and for
context we see this across twenty
thousand
um uh funds and syndicates and 13 000
Stars so we are pretty much uh have a
very very broad view of the market at
this point
and so
from a fundraising perspective it
actually is uh you know when you anchor
it back on 2019 2020 it's fairly healthy
yes a deal count is down it is harder
but again um humans just anchor on like
the highest possible thing and then uh
and now we're like oh no fundraising is
down complete but it's actually a pretty
healthy Market out there
um in terms of what we're seeing around
how rounds are getting done
um I would say at the earliest stages
pre-seed and Seed
um there are the party rounds right
they're coming together we are seeing
more
um more leads relative to the past but
they're still a pretty healthy set of
activity around like a bunch of
investors coming in no single lead for
preseason seed
um series a series B series C has always
been you should get an anchor and go
from there just because the dollar is a
much larger
um so we're not really seeing any
departure in that behavior we are seeing
actually one thing I will add we are
seeing I would say the later stages
again this is a reflection of I would
say 2021 2022 where companies that are
starting to hit that brick wall for
those companies we are seeing
additional
terms coming in around the additional
you know 2x 3x liquidation preference uh
pay to plays so that is happening but
that's healthy that's that's a very
unique moment for startups that raise
then
um and there are now basically trying to
deal with that situation but in general
if you're starting off today like the
fundraising markets fairly healthy one
of the things I've seen
um some of its rolling funds some of its
rubs some of its Founders have just been
at this now kind of through a zero
interest rate environment over the last
decade or so and people have gotten
liquidity more Founders are saying hey
I'm going to run my business but I also
want to become an angel investor yeah
and so they're starting to invest what
are you either seeing there or what is
some of the advice that you would give
to Founders that are you know Focus 99.9
of their time on their company but they
also want to begin to invest and kind of
dabble in that side of the market yeah
this is a heavy debate typically um
so
I would say what we're seeing is um for
anyone who's post product Market fit and
they end up raising a small fund and
deploying it it's actually similar to
them investing their personal Capital
anyways
um they do they typically do pretty well
mainly because when you're postpartum
Market as a Founder you also just have
DFO that comes in naturally I think if
you're a pre-product market fit and you
don't have a brand
um it it is it is tougher you kind of
have to focus on your company you have
to focus on building your company
because when your pre-product Market fit
like the only thing that matters is get
the product Market fit and nothing else
matters
um so typically we see folks that are
postpart Market fit Founders raising a
fund because it's just an extension of
their personal investing anyways uh and
that does do pretty well uh and every
now and then we'll see someone who was a
Founder they exit and now they decide to
go into investing full-time the one
thing about rolling funds that does make
it interesting is rolling funds um
just for context it's it's something
ageless invented uh in 2019 2020 and it
basically uh reduces the friction for
fundraising into a venture fund so a
typical Venture fund for context someone
will say okay great I want to go invest
in startups let's say I want to raise 10
million dollars I'm going to now go out
and fundraise you find an anchor and
then you fill up the rest of the fund
and then you start investing then uh
every two years we just took a
deployment period or three years you
then have to go raise another funds
start from scratch rolling funds
basically took that and said what if you
could make the fundraising a
subscription so it just keeps flowing
forward so you can invest every quarter
or every year and the subscription just
reviewed just like your Netflix
subscription so you can invest 100K 500k
a year but it just renews instantly so
it actually reduces the friction for
someone coming into your fund and
because of that that ends up being
actually really good product for
Founders that want to have a fund
because they don't need to worry about
the additional fundraising and the fund
will just continue growing and they can
just continue deploying it so we do
naturally see Founders gravitating to
that product like I'm personally honored
as well I rolled my personal investing
into it
um and then you'll see uh folks who are
looking for the more anchor investors do
the traditional Venture fund now the one
thing uh just to Anchor back on like why
Angelus does all of this we originally
started again like I mention the sort of
the founder and we existed uh accelerate
the rate of innovation in the world and
believe startups Founders are really a
driving force in that and um what we did
was we actually focused on at the
beginning the earliest stage of
fundraising pre-seed and seed and we
built a product that effectively allowed
a lot more people to get into Venture
raise Capital deploy Capital so preced
found receive Founders can actually have
additional investors to raise from uh
because at the earliest stages uh it's
it's more of an art than a science you
need someone to believe in you to write
that first check uh so that you can get
going and Angelus basically created the
market because we reduced the cost got
more people in uh so any any fund less
than 50 million basically fit stock
bucket uh uh investing in the preseason
seed stage
um and so for you know for us it's a
positive benefit to the ecosystem where
Founders have a lot more
investors the first one let's talk about
the change maybe in strategy the
startups have had over the last 18 24
months um growth at all cost now maybe
there's even better over rotation to
like have to have cash right I got to
get some sort of cash flow and uh not
grow at all cost
um that then lends more of itself to
private Equity I know you guys have done
some expansion in your private Equity
just talk about like where's the balance
between you know spending Venture
dollars to grow versus trying to operate
your business to actually drive cash
yeah
um
the way I think about this and the way
we think about it internally is you have
your core business and uh especially in
this environment if you're
um if you're not operating towards
getting to break even and being default
alive like strong recommendation to do
that there are exceptions of course if
you're uh growing you know 200 300 400
uh Breakneck pace and you think it will
continue to grow in this environment go
for it but generally you want to operate
so that your uh default alive now as
your core business continues to grow and
you make new product bets
um the way that we approach it is all
the product bats are very tightly
constrained it's a small team and we're
watching how that particular product is
growing and then based off of that we
actually move from a phase of like zero
to one which is you can think of it as
best as like okay this is an early stage
startup and then we move it to one to
end that's what we call it internally
which is great this is ready for scale
and now we can drive more dollars to it
so we actually have that discipline in
the company uh every quarter we have an
off site where we basically broken the
entire company down by Opex who are the
people what products are they actually
working on so you can just literally
think of a spreadsheet names of all
everyone in the company as a row and
then we have products that we're working
on as at columns and then we have people
that are allocated to each one and then
we're able to understand okay how much
have we spent in this particular product
line and then what's the
um what's the momentum they have What's
the progress they've made and then we're
able to assess and go okay do we want to
continue investing here or not and to be
clear it's it's not always a like
scientific calculation of like nope this
much burn they haven't hit this Revenue
it's it's a little bit more again it
goes back like earliest investing in
some more Art and Science but at least
gives us the natural constraints to
understand how are we spending our
dollars where do we need to invest more
versus less uh and it also gives
everyone in the company a common
framework for how we make decisions
now when you think about metrics inside
of the business how do you actually put
this into practice right you you kind of
have new products and there's things
that you're probably trying to figure
out you've got old products that you
know work and have found product Market
fit what is the process for identifying
what metrics you're going to use for
these new products and then how do you
track them is this a hourly process a
daily a weekly yeah just talk a little
bit as to kind of like measuring you
know we're launching something new is it
working yeah uh I would say um a zero to
one product and this is the case for any
startup that's that's just launching a
product uh what you're really looking
for is product Market fit and typically
product Market fit um the best way to
measure it is just do people love it
honestly like this is even one person
love your product do two people love it
to five people love it most of the times
no one loves it uh you know you're
essentially fighting apathy
um and so for us that's what we look at
we're just asking hey do people love
this product like what we've built do
they love it are we seeing signs of
um of uh let's just call it engagement
it really it's another product but that
you can definitely measure some Metric
that's some sign of Engagement where
people are just pulling it out of you uh
and you know if there's one if there's
one thing I could somehow and maybe with
neurolink we will be able to just
explain to Founders like what product
Market fit feels like because you know
most people think they have product
Market they don't like product Market
fit just feels like the Park's getting
pulled out of you that you just you
can't hang on like there's just so many
things that are breaking because
customers are banging down the door when
we launch rolling funds we literally had
uh people pinging
um my like friends on LinkedIn to try
and get access to like rolling funds uh
it was it was absolutely just insane
like it was just oh like it was
overflowing with uh with the man
um and so
that's what we look for would be zero to
one products it's it's more around
um engagement like customer love and all
of that then for something that starts
to scale now it looks a little bit more
uh like a traditional focus of Revenue
um uh it looks like what does the
pipeline Health look like so if it's
it's more of an enterprising product
than what is top of the funnel pipeline
look like what close race look like
um so 110 it's a little bit more
systematic and you can you can
effectively look at other metrics you
can Benchmark yourself against other
companies but zero to one is just does
anyone love it
let's talk talent and kind of hiring I
know you guys had a kind of a talent
part of the business you spun that out
into a separate company uh but you're
obviously hiring yourselves what are you
seeing there in terms of compensation
packages that you're having to put
together that maybe 2019 2021 and today
um and then also the quality of the
talent you know when markets draw down
sometimes people want to run into the
fire other people say hey I'm going to
go back and take my job at Facebook or
Google and you know just chill for two
or three years and take the easy life
what are you seeing there yeah we've um
I would say
what we're seeing there is um folks who
are interested in working at startups
they're they're definitely starting to
to take the jumps out we're not actually
seeing too much of a drag there I will
say though that the the general rate of
turnover has slowed down right relative
to 2020 and 2022 so what this means is
folks are generally staying put but you
also have a positive selection bias of
people who want to go take a chance on a
startup or at least a startup or Jumping
Ship some of that could just be the
overhang of blood right on their company
um some of it could be like hey there's
no better time is we'll just do it now
but we are generally broadly speaking
we're seeing people stay put but then
you have positive selection bias of
folks who do want to jump into startups
they are making a jump
um I would say in terms of our like
recruiting at angelist
um it's actually really really strong
and um and we we also look to hire
ex-founders
um and we're we're seeing that being
pretty healthy and some of it's just
because again we're kind of cycle where
a lot of companies are starts are
shutting down and folks are getting back
in it out in the market so from that
perspective it's actually pretty great
I've heard Naval I've heard nivi I've
heard you I've heard other Executives at
Angel has continued to say we hire
ex-founders describe a little less like
why is that such an important part of
where you guys go look for talent yeah
and then once they're inside the
organization what benefits do you see
from it yeah I mean I mentioned this
earlier right the um unique culture
carriers uh so if you're going to serve
Founders like overall as a mission for
the company and you're going to build
products very quickly you need Founders
who understand that you can move quickly
right um because if you've worked at a
larger organization uh where there's a
bunch of process flow and it takes
longer to get something out the door and
you only hire from there then you you
bring people in the organization that
think that's how products get built but
that's not how products get built that's
actually how products go to die and so
Founders when you bring them in they can
inject that source of energy into the
company because they do understand that
you can move really fast right
you don't need to uh you don't need to
wait uh like weeks months at all uh you
know what when um my second company was
bought by square and so I'd spend about
two uh two and a half years around the
acquisition tournament square and uh
when we came in we actually had to take
what we built and we launch it within
the uh within the product there and uh
it was pretty clear that within the
broader process it was going to take
months and so what we did I was just
like it let's just go to uh like
one of the top floors no one was there
locked ourselves in a conference room so
every day whoever's working in the
project just came up went there and we
just got it done in a couple of weeks
and launched the thing and so again you
just have you need founder energy and
founder mentality to break through the
process breakthrough any other drag so
that you can just focus on shipping
great product and focusing on what
matters and the reason Founders are very
good at this is because if you've
started a company you've had to go
through a range of things you've got to
raise money you got to build the initial
product you got to motivate the team you
have to launch you have to listen to
feedback and because you've gone through
that range you just have a broader
experience to pull from and so for us we
just find that very valuable talk about
the engineering Talent obviously now
with this move to remote you're talking
about people being in person I think the
argument for remote is that you can get
Talent anywhere in the world right and
you can do cheaper better Etc
um is that true in terms of what you
guys are seeing and how do you think
about the balance between you talked
earlier about people in person and kind
of the culture versus you know an
amazing engineer somewhere else in the
world and the ability to work with them
what how do you net out yeah so I'm
gonna get canceled for this one um
so don't worry me too
um okay
so I think if you're hiring a very
senior engineer I think it can work
remotely but I'm talking to senior
engineer or designer is like a savant
right we actually have someone like that
that worked at ageless
um actually even before the pandemic in
2019 and he's just a savant like I mean
just everything he builds is pure art is
super fast uh very independent but I
think for most people
um and especially someone just coming
out of school they crave being in person
they have to learn from others and what
we're actually seeing actually going
back to recruiting is that people who
are just coming out of school and
especially the ambitious ones the ones
who want to become Founders are saying
I'm actually rejecting offers where
their company is remote I want to be in
person uh we actually had this happen in
a normal pipeline too it's like hey if
uh this was like a while ago before we
started reverted back to coming back in
office
um it's like hey if you guys can
continue remote it's not going to be a
fit
um and so again if you want to hire the
best young talent you have to be in
person it's just very very hard to for
them to learn by osmosis
um so that's one piece I think the
second piece is
um you're just able to communicate a lot
more when you're in person and so when
you're in the early stages of building a
product and your pre-product Market fit
there's just a lot of information you
you're not optimizing for efficiency
you're actually optimizing for
creativity and when you're optimize for
creativity you you have to be in person
you're typically jamming through
different ideas uh you're building
something you're launching it but then
when you're remote especially time zones
like if your time zones are so far apart
guess what you have some idea today you
send it out now you wait for I don't
know 24 hours until someone uh responds
back well you've just lost your flow
your flow is gone or if you have to wait
to schedule a zoom meeting and hop on
the zoom meeting it's again it just
breaks the entire flow so what we've
just found is when folks are in person
uh and you can optimize for that for you
to flow you just get a lot more creative
ideas out of it now it is a little bit
tougher as you scale like for example
Angelus has we have three offices San
Francisco New York and Seattle
um but then what what I just do is going
I just say look we're going to solve
some hard problem it like fly out
here later this week or next week and
we're all meeting in person we're not
leaving the room until we solve this
problem and we build this thing
um and so that's the way you also solve
for it is just fly people out get this
done in person because you can't
solve hard problems in my view
so I want to talk about Frontier
Technologies or opportunity and ambition
one of the benefits of the position that
you have is you got a hard day job of
you got to go build the product and kind
of a company but you also get to talk to
some of the best Founders in the world
right and so you're seeing a lot of
where Talent is Flowing where's Capital
flowing but also what's working and
what's not working yeah
um there's a number of different sectors
that I think people are very interested
in so there's kind of Bitcoin
cryptocurrency artificial intelligence
space the whole Renaissance and energy
these are things that are not kind of
your traditional B2B SAS type business
what are you seeing that is actually
working and then maybe are there areas
where you're like yeah I know a lot of
people are talking about that but it's
probably more you know kind of smoke
than actual fire
yeah I mean it's always really tough I
mean to the smoke and actual fire like
early on right it's because again it's
it's part of the zero to one you're
you're trying to build something and you
don't quite know where the world's going
um I I think I'll kind of talk I'll
start with off with the aips because AI
is actually not really a category in its
own it's actually seeping into
everything every single industry I think
on on the AI side the one thing we are
seeing is that you have companies that
are uh starting Founders that are
starting and then actually pivoting
pretty quickly because the underlying
infrastructure is just changing really
really fast so when you're underlying
infrastructure is changing fast you
don't know where the world is going to
settle in and so we are seeing Founders
pivoting a lot more because what they
thought could be a great business uh now
just got commoditizer just got folded
into open AI like maybe an open AI
release you know open-ended release a
new feature and all of a sudden it's
monetized so I think generally we're
seeing a lot of
call a change just within Ai and like
all the companies that are building up
in and around it
um we I would say by funding just by
dollars overall of course a lot of
dollars just by Nature goes to some of
the uh you know uh you may want to call
it space Tech just because it needs a
lot more dollars uh we are seeing a lot
of dollars go there but not seeing as
much interest from founders like
relatively speaking right relatively
speaking
um if you're a Founder that's starting a
new company
um you're probably going to start a new
company in something that's more
software based because you just you're
getting going you don't quite know
enough about space technology you don't
know enough about maybe even sometimes
crypto right because so on this this is
interesting right if you look at Elon
maybe it's a quite essential example
like he kind of got a single or a double
and then he went for the home run right
um we've seen this over and over again
in history how important is it it's
almost like kind of get your legs under
you get some confidence of like okay you
know I know how to build a business and
then go for the really hard thing versus
um I don't you know I don't know if it
was in Palmer uh lucky right like he
kind of went for it right out of the
gate and it was this weird thing and
everyone's like you know he's putting a
box on his face is it gonna work yeah
like how do you think about those two
strategies of if you're 22 25 years old
do you just go for the big thing or do
the odds tell you no go build something
make it work get some money and then go
try for the big thing I think you just
need to follow whatever unique Insight
unique Viewpoint you have of the world
um because ultimately it like any
company building your product you build
your your your imprinting some view you
have of the world uh some opinion of how
the world should exist and that's what
you're doing and you're building a
product around that and so if you have a
view of the world that is goes directly
into something around space or something
uh around cars even go do it right
um so I don't think there's any like
recipe for Stark here then go here then
go here
um But ultimately comes down to like do
you have enough experience to have it
any Viewpoint or not and if you do go
for it uh because again I would say the
fundraising Market is actually quite
healthy
um for taking those sets of big shocks
um but again it comes from like what's
your unique view uh and are you drawing
from some pool of experience are you
starting from scratch and I always loved
the idea of the or the concept of the
idea maze I think apology first talked
about it and then it was posted up on
a16z blog and the idea maze is basically
if you look at any founder who started a
successful company and you trace that
you know you trace their um interest in
the company back they've been thinking
about it for a long time they've been
sitting in that idea maze for a long
time connecting all the dots and by the
time they start the company and they go
to scale the company it's like four
years in anyways so that's another
influence concept so it all come down to
that like how long have you been
thinking about do you have unique
insight
now one of the key themes I see over and
over again is many of the biggest
companies in the world start out as
science projects or almost a joke and so
Google obviously they want to sell for a
million bucks they were just like oh
this is a cool paper like let's get it
you know let's take a million dollars go
buy a nice car and leave
um Uber literally Travis didn't even run
the company at first like he was kind of
like oh this would be cool to get you
know a baller thing where I press a
button the car shows up even if you look
at varda Delian basically tweeted and
was like oh interest rates are low I
should just go raise a bunch of free
money and then like try to go
manufacture things in space yeah and
then he was kind of like I might
around and find out this works right and
book copy this now worth hundreds of
millions of dollars and so how do you
think about the intentionality of like I
am starting a company let me go do you
know customer research and and really
kind of understand what the problem is
versus some of these really large
companies people kind of back their way
into it and it almost starts out as like
a toy or a joke yeah
um I see more of like the Toyota joke as
in you're experimenting you put
something out there and then if it works
you can go around it it's actually
something I picked up from the ball a
few years ago where when you think about
early stage companies it's actually
about a small team a Founder maybe the
founding team sitting uh crafting
creating something and then you know
they're not kind of in their like lab
and then they put it out in the world
and they're like hey do you like this
and then most of the time the world is
just like no like I don't give a
right go back and then you go back you
know you kind of crawl back in you're
like okay back to work again and you're
kind of crafting and then you come back
out and you're like hey do you like this
yeah I think notion famously
um I think notion the product that
worked I think was like version two or
version three yeah a bunch of slack
which came out of full rebuild again
kind of a similar concept so when you
look at that across all of these
different companies you'll actually see
a period in time where you're just
sitting there just
um uh crafting a product they think
could work in the world and then they're
putting it out there and so I think a
lot of the times it comes from the
founders not knowing because you don't
know you she you can't you can't know
ahead of time whether the product is
going to work and you can only know when
you actually put it out of the world
um and uh and and people are saying yep
I love it and then they pull it out of
you and then when they pull it out of
you then the question is can this be a
big company like can this growth sustain
or maybe like what if it tapers out
um and but that's actually an easier uh
question to answer than like the early
stage of like will this work you just
don't know it's the same thing you know
go back to Uber who knows like I mean it
was just a a block bar Service uh who
knew like how could you have predicted
that yep you can actually bring the cost
down you can bring you'll actually
literally bring a lot more people into
the supply side of the market to start
driving their cars
um so I would actually say more often
than not it's uh it's it's not perfectly
planned you can't quite predict it
take that same idea now bring it inside
of a couple like Angel lists uh you all
don't have the Good Fortune of hiding
right I think a lot about you know use
Bitcoin as an example like probably some
of its success was just like no one was
paying attention and so it could kind of
flourish without critiques and critics
and all this kind of stuff evangelist
does anything yeah if you guys breed on
the internet somebody notices and
there's an article written yeah how do
you test ideas how do you know this is
worth potential a hit to the brand or
you know kind of failure being in public
and taking these ideas like it almost
has to start as a toy or you know
something you're playing with but you're
doing inside this company where you
don't get credit for hey we're just you
know we're in the arena testing things
if you will yeah I just tweet them in
the arena so
actually I and I say that in the most
positive way possible I don't care in
the sense that
um when you so okay if you actually
study uh if you study history of
Entrepreneurship and you actually
studied the grades who've built
companies from like hundreds of years
ago uh like I'm talking uh uh the
Polaroid founder talking about
um you know talking about even like Bill
Gates Building Microsoft like if you
start studying all of these Founders
you'll notice that there's just so much
tinkering that happened there's so much
experimentation that happens and there
will be false starts but when you look
at it through the uh you know um uh when
you look at our cross time it just
doesn't matter these are all like little
blips so even if Angela salons launches
something that doesn't work it's a black
yeah maybe there's an article written uh
maybe there's some opinion piece or some
blog post but it honestly just doesn't
matter because all we're really here to
do is just build an enduring company and
building an enduring company takes a lot
about it takes a lot of experimentation
and I think the second you start looking
at what others are saying about you
you're not building what customers
actually want from you and the only
thing that matters is what customers
want from you not what others are saying
about you because who cares now of
course it doesn't mean that you know
we're making a lot of egregious like
decisions
um because Angelus we are in a regulated
space
um and uh you know we we have actually
we're kind of sitting across different
pieces of Regulation because we are not
just under the Venture exemption we're
also we have an Ria
um and so we do we do have to be careful
about that but generally we lean more
towards taking more advanced and more
experiments uh and not really caring
about what others let's talk about
Capital allocation you know when you
have multiple bets kind of going on at
the same time some are mature some are
not mature how do you think about one um
the new bets is there a dollar amount is
there a head count like how do you say
like hey these are the resources we're
basically willing to like lose over
whether this works or not yeah and then
how do you think about feeding the
machine you know the thing that's
already working and kind of is there a
framework or is it a case-by-case
decision yeah I mean the framework I I
lightly mentioned earlier which is we'll
we'll generally have a good idea of what
products people are working on with the
support business or a new product
and then anything that's a new product
like a zero to one
um will effectively treat it as a
pre-seed company
um uh and we'll say all right you
generally have this much an allocation
this much Capital uh to go with and
there's a product lead there's a product
lead where we actually frame it as look
this is your startup
um and here are the you know the team uh
the team members you have and you can
also say you don't want this person to
work with you and that's okay uh because
you want to keep a very tight team and
then we'll actually see the progress
they're making across multiple quarters
or even sometimes mid quarter we'll just
do a check-in on it
um and so we're pretty tightly scoped
based off of that and then for the Core
Business it really depends on the stage
and it depends on the scale of the
business uh and we really think about it
as will more Capital accelerate it or
not and more often than not more Capital
those will not accelerate right I think
the uh one of the things that got lost
in uh 2021 uh and 2020 to the beginning
part of 20 by two is this assumption
that hey raise more Capital you can go
faster but in reality most companies
cannot go faster when you raise more
Capital there are exceptions like if
you're in the I've spent a lot of time
in the logistics space
um where you do need more Capital you
have to launch multiple cities you
literally have to pay out for every city
you launch but for vast majority
companies like software companies you
don't need more Capital to scale or at
least that is not the that's not what's
on critical path so it's actually very
rare that more Capital means you grow
faster so you have to kind of break down
into Core Business is more Capital the
issue or is there some other issue
that's uh preventing you from scaling
um and so or can you actually just take
the cash that's coming off you know uh
getting generated from the company and
invest that and then keep the money you
raised separately so that's the way we
think about on the core business side
it's like is capital really the issue or
not
um and in general we actually lean
towards not burning cash for the sake of
it I mean that sounds obvious but you
know I think a lot of people just
literally just like hey the next round
is on around the corner we don't think
that way and in fact even if you take a
look at Angelus history before the round
that we raise in uh beginning of last
year we hadn't race half capital in I
don't know four or five years it was
just a long time so we haven't actually
like for being actually first for for
being the platform for a lot of venture
funds uh you know we have a pretty large
percent of the market for Venture funds
we don't raise a lot of cash we haven't
gone back out to the market uh
you let me invest I appreciate you
thank you
um another part of cap allocation is
protecting the cash you do have and
treasury management
um I think that a lot of tech startups
really just have the idea of like I put
it in the bank and I'm good uh in the
crypto world I think they over the last
couple years realize like that's not
good right like there could be some
problems uh and they actually were the
ones who avoided kind of the bank run
the fastest because like I've seen this
Playbook before yeah um but the people
who hadn't had that experience Silicon
Valley Bank signature these different
organizations first public Etc how do
you all think about it now and you guys
have built some products here that kind
of how people with treasury management
so like what are their best practices or
what are you guys doing uh to kind of
think about the cash you do have on the
balance sheet yeah yeah it's funny yeah
because before svb everyone's like this
keep it at svb and that's perfect
um was in my bingo cards that that was
gonna happen
um the way that we do treasury
management is uh and and this would
recommend for all startups is you
typically want to take the cash you have
and you want to make sure that you're
putting it in a place where it it either
is uh in U.S credit rebuilds
um or you actually have to cross
multiple Banks or you have one of the
big big Banks the problem with one of
the big big Banks is they just don't
want to work with you right I mean JP
Morgan
um or uh you know Bank of America uh
actually well one some of their uis is
terrible but in general they don't
typically like working with small like
early stage startups so what I would
recommend is uh actually uh you know
putting your money into into a banking
solution where the money actually gets
spread out across multiple Banks uh so
you actually have 100 FDIC Insurance
um and uh take anything you want to earn
yield and just put in U.S treasury so
typically have you know three months six
months of Runway that's in in a bank
account so you can just pay the bills
make sure everything running smoothly
and then take the rest and you put into
those treasuries uh what Angelus does
like what we do ourselves is we actually
have it we actually have it spread
across some of the big big Banks uh and
then we have money that goes into a
sweep account that goes into the U.S
treasuries one of the topics that
Founders have to face when they go from
a very early stage company to some
degree of success this could be they
raise the series a or series B it could
be product Market fit whatever kind of
Milestone that brings up the
conversation is co compensation and it's
always this weird thing where every time
I've had the conversation whether I'm on
the board or I'm just an investor the
CEO is like hey I'm used to thinking of
the compensation decisions for everyone
else yeah I want the company to succeed
I know we're trying to keep costs down
but also like I have a family or I want
to live my life or you know whatever how
have you both at Angelus but also in
other places seeing CEOs kind of
navigate this correctly and are there
any best practices that you think other
Founders should take away yeah it's it's
a tough one
um I would say it depends by stage right
if your pre-seed seat
um you could theoretically try and get
uh you know some Market comps and try
and set it that way but in reality at
precedent seed you're just looking to
preserve as much cash as possible right
you're getting paid handsomely in equity
uh as a founder and what you wanted it's
actually in your incentive to keep your
burn for the company as low as possible
and also keep your personal burden as
low as possible and so my my advice for
precedency Founders is take as little as
you need because you actually want the
company to have as little bird as
possible because you need to make
progress to get to the next stage and
the next stage after that I think once
you
series a again a little bit post-proc
Market fit series 8 series B series C
then it's actually more of a science
there's a lot of comp data out there to
the way that Angelus does it uh we have
a comp committee
um of course if it's you know discussing
my pay then I have to accuse myself
um uh and but we have a comp committee
there's one uh you know a couple of
folks on there
that are also sitting on other boards
and they have a lot of this data so it
is actually more of a science as you get
to later and later stage and I would
actually look to the uh to the VC as
well as someone external someone who's
actually an independent sitting on comp
committees or maybe a public company and
you can have someone you can have
someone else to lean on so that's what I
would do it for life series a series B
series so another piece of this again
which is kind of like a tough
conversation I think for both the
founder and also the investors the
secondaries for the founder and on one
hand Founders have you know 99.9 of
their net worth tied up in a company
especially with their first one that's
really successful
um and I think from an investor
standpoint they don't want the founder
to be worried and stressed out about
they shouldn't be stressed out
about yeah on the other hand the
greatest you know kind of risk is the
founder takes a multi-million dollar
secondary even if it's a small
percentage of ownership and then they've
got a Ferrari and you know they're
trying to get distracted yeah what have
you seen there that's worked or kind of
if you were sitting on the board or an
investor you would kind of guide the
founder to think about it yeah
um
I I kind of anchor back to 2018 2019 and
what the norm was then and I would say
the norm then was
if you're getting to series a series B
uh there it was not common practice but
uh it was it was fine for a Founder to
take a couple million off the table and
the incentives are actually very much
aligned with the investors uh and the
shareholders because by doing that you
actually take a little bit of that
pressure off the table for the founder
and again everyone's Situation's
different it depends on if the founders
already had liquidity in the past so
this thing doesn't matter or if they
haven't and you know they've been
spending five years six years on it and
and they have a specific uh personal
financial needs so it's really a honest
conversation that has to happen but
generally you know taking a couple
million off the table to relieve some of
that pressure does align you with all
the shareholders and the investors
because it means you're going to be more
likely to go for the big home run the
big group Grand Slam versus looking to
sell the company and
um you know once you get to that post
product pocket fit moment and the
company scaling and if it's a healthy
company you will get acquisition offers
will be tempting it's like oh wow it's
life-changing money for the founder and
interestingly enough I would say the
incentives do skew when you have a um
when you actually uh get bought that out
when you come to get spot and it's not a
massive outcome the incentives are
excused because of the founder it's
life-changing money but for the investor
it it doesn't matter because the way
Venture works is when you invest in uh
in a portfolio of companies you're
hoping for one or two or three of them
to become massive companies grand slams
and a company that ends up 2X and 3X and
Forex saying uh yeah is is just it's
surrounding here it doesn't matter and
it was actually one of the most
perplexing things for me as a Founder
but now that I'm running ageless I fully
understand it it's like oh why why do
investors not care about the 2x or 3x
it's like oh right it literally is a
running error it doesn't even matter
it's in the Venture map it just it it's
not where all the returns are made
describe this a little bit more because
I think people who have experience
investing will understand but from a
Investor's standpoint maybe just
describe like what is the investor
thinking in that scenario as to why two
to three x doesn't matter yeah so
the way to think about it is um when you
go to raise a venture fund
um uh so every investor is typically not
investing on personal Capital until
they're unless they're initial investing
but by and large you should assume
they're actually investing other
people's Capital so when you start a
venture fund you go race from other
people just like I found it a Founder is
from investors and a VCU raises from
their own investors and what they do is
they raise this capital and they have a
specific strategy and they're going to
invest in let's say 20 companies or 25
companies now it's in the Venture map
that by investing the 20 or 25 companies
probably two maybe three if you're good
are going to be massive like uh you know
massive home runs and the rest of them
will kind of be like a 1x or will just
be a complete write-off because again
you're investing in early stage
companies the uh the survival rate of
companies uh venture-backed companies is
like two and a half percent or one or
two percent and then of those the ones
that actually become enduring companies
like large sustainable companies is like
point one percent so when you do that is
literally the Venture map so when you
take that back into Adventure fund and
you look at it portfolio let's say 20
companies when only two or three
companies are the ones that are going to
be massive fund returners uh and
actually return a lot of capital that's
where the investor actually makes what's
called their carry which is they get a
profit off of or they get a cut of the
profits off the Venture fund so the
incentives are aligned with the
companies that will be grand slams uh
it's not aligned with companies that
will be the 1X or 2x or 3x but for the
founder if if you own forty percent
fifty percent sixty percent and the
outcome is thirty million 40 million
that's pretty good that is life-changing
money
um so again going back to the question
earlier of does it make sense for
Founders to take a secondary I would say
yes within reason uh and and this was
you know some part of the practice in
2018 2019 because it allowed them to go
for the brand slam it'll allowed them to
like relieve that pressure so that when
there is an acquisition offer they're
just more likely to say hey not a right
fit I think this company can be uh can
continue to scale now as part of
building these companies and kind of
talking about taking secondaries paying
yourself
Etc uh there's some things that you can
do at the beginning of the company to
set yourself up as a Founder
um some people in this room it's gonna
be too late right they kind of already
messed it up
um but there's things like qsps Etc like
if you were to go back and start a
company today what are like the one or
two big decisions that you would really
try to get right so that if the company
ended up being a big success you would
be thankful you did that at the start of
the setup of the company yeah yeah
um I think one of the biggest decisions
is actually the distribution of equity
amongst the founders so
um I I would really ask do you need
equal co-founders or do you need a late
co-founder uh and the reason I frame it
this way is because typically companies
uh venture-backed companies and really
every company is authoritative right you
have a single a leader a single CEO
who's going to lead the company and a
lot of like a lot of the successive and
failure the company is going to write on
that one person and you should really
ask like can you start the company
yourself and you basically get more
Equity if you're gonna be the CEO of the
company and then are you looking to
bring in a late co-founder and it's not
to say that the distribution of equity
needs to be like 95 five percent but I
think generally making sure that out the
gate you set the right stage in terms of
allocation solves for a lot of the
potential founder breakup issues that
come out in the future because if you're
equal co-founders but one person is
actually taking on a lot of the
leadership for us that and uh if there
are decisions that need to be made
decisions don't get made by consensus
and startups at all it has to be
authoritative uh it has to be a singular
person that's accountable to it and if
you have an equal co-founder
relationship it can cause a lot of
tension so I think that's one of the
most important things now I would say
structurally there are things that you
can optimize for sure every startup
qualifies what's called qsbs qsbs
basically means for any you know for any
um if you have a liquidity event for any
outcome that reaches uh up to 10 million
it's basically tax-free at the federal
level I believe I can remember
California has that or not
um and you qualify for qsps
um you could do some other optimizations
uh though I think some of them may some
of the loopholes may be closing out
either see like you take some of the
equity and you put it into like
different crusts right and there's
different PSPs on like every single one
um as a Founder you could do it but I
just don't know if it's worth the
trouble uh I would just focus on just
get the product Market fit there are
other things you could do like founder
preferred stock
um though I think in this market it'll
be a little bit harder some of these
things get negotiated out anyways in
later rounds
um so my my advice actually is the
number one thing is the is the equity
split between the founders and look if
you really want vehicle co-founders go
for it but generally I think having a
step down in equity based off the second
founder third founder
um works well because then you can
actually it can be clear who's actually
running the business
5149 or like 70 30 when you talk about
not having equal like how how egregious
yeah these two egregious and does it
actually matter or is it more of just
literally you're the authoritative
decision maker and someone else is kind
of like the second you know Authority
decision maker it could be that but
sometimes uh you know goes back to you
just take a look at the incentives right
um personally again this is just my
opinion I would say more like 70 30 60
40 than like 49 49.51 just looks cute
right it's like kind of a cute thing to
do but 60 40 70 30 is it can work
um and then I'd say if you actually have
a late co-founder meaning they join
later on they're taking a lot less risk
then it could be like 10 50 and you're
85 90 and that actually does work pretty
well like I've started a company where I
brought in like co-founder was awesome
um uh sometimes it can work if you bring
on a key higher later on right the
company's been around for for your I'm
close with one company
um uh you know it's been operating for a
year and a half brought in a cro gave
that person I think five percent uh
which is very healthy and ended up being
game changing for the company
um so again every Situation's uh
different but generally I'm seeing the
stuff down in equity of course
one other thing I want to talk about is
um technology companies are usually
pretty good at Building Products they're
almost always horrible at sales and
marketing and there's like this big
difference
um one of the things when I worked at
Facebook that was always so funny to me
is like there's no customer service
number yeah and when you first get there
you're like hey should we have a
customer no we shouldn't here's kind of
logic why and then it makes sense yeah
talk a little bit as to like how much of
it is just like the product itself
itself and as you said you know people
are like literally finding your LinkedIn
connections like begging for the product
versus being able to really go out there
explain to people what does this do have
a sales team and kind of build what I
think most people would consider more
traditional type of company yeah
um I I don't think of it as like an
either or
um
I think it all starts with a great
product so you know forced to choose
where you allocate your dollars
um we allocated towards product versus
allocating into our sales and marketing
um and you'll sometimes I mean you can
basically look at the income statement
of any company and basically tell like
hey are they a product of that company
are they sales and marketing lead
company
um and typically sales and marketing
like companies a lot more of the dollars
go into sales and marketing s m versus
um uh or in the like the design
engineering product so generally my take
is that you want to be a product-led
company because by being a product like
company you can actually focus on real
Innovation uh one of the things that we
think about an angel list is uh we
should we don't want to build a better
version of the past
most products are just building a better
version of the past and the reason
that's a problem is when you're building
a better version of the past you're
building a commodity product and when
you build a commodity product
um it goes back to like you're fighting
apathy right and no one cares they're
like well why not just use this thing
that's already there it's good enough
and hearing that from a customer is like
oh this other thing I use is good enough
is the worst and so you want to focus on
building something that's insanely great
that is just so much better than the
past right imagine the uh depending on
how old folks are here but first time
you pick up an iPhone from going from a
Blackberry right just absolutely insane
it's just insanely better for somebody
wrote a Tesla relative to any other car
it's just insanely better and so the
only way you do that is be having a
ruthless focus on building a great
product now for sales and marketing
I will say that depending on the type of
product you're building and selling if
you're selling the Enterprises and your
uh size of the contract is twenty five
thousand thirty thousand fifty thousand
or requires coordination across multiple
teams personally I've never seen that
work through pure product LED growth um
I think that's when you do need a sales
team and you do because again you have
to talk to a human once you get past 25k
an average contract value there's
approval processes that happened
internally they have to justify it so
that's what we see so going back to what
you mentioned with rolling funds
um are like for majority of the history
of Angelus we had like one sales person
and we had no marketing team like it was
just pure product like world as we
entered and entered larger uh larger
fund sizes all of a sudden now we do
have a sales motion because the ACV goes
up the average contract value goes up
and you need more of a
um uh you know a kind of tackling motion
to make sure that we're getting in front
of the right people and then we're
selling the product there but it still
starts with having a great product to
get in the door but then when you sell
larger acvs you just need uh you need a
sales team
sure my last question for you is
um ambition and the importance of it for
startups and kind of
um you know it's Friday night it's two
o'clock in the morning this sucks
I'm eating glass I've been doing it for
you know six six years six months
whatever it is how important is the
ambition and the motivation to kind of
some people go oh I mean it's everything
I mean it's everything like it's
look it's it's not easy at all
um my you know first startup uh uh you
know we um with my co-founder at the
time I think we built like 20 companies
or 20 products before we actually even
landed on something to raise money and
it was just like soul sucking and then
we finally built something and then we
figured out how to scale it and then we
didn't have broad Market Fair we got
distribution we didn't have any product
Market fit and then I ran that thing for
another two and a half years and it was
soul sucking right and you know coming
out of it you're just like nope gotta
keep going
um and it just came from a sense of no I
actually I just I'm viewing this as a
stepping so I'm doing this as something
that I'm learning from so I can go build
something even better and then that led
to the second company uh that actually
ended up getting acquired in like you
know very quickly in like six months
which then was a complete step function
change so what I'm trying to say here is
that startups are a step function change
it will never ever ever feel linear ever
it's always always a stop function
change you start off with you're
building a product you're crafting in
the lab and you're putting out in the
world and then people SWAT it most of
the time you're like oh crap you have to
go back right your back you it feels
like you're back to zero because you are
you know in a way but in some ways
you've already learned something and now
you can iterate to the next thing so
it's not linear and you'll do another
try at it another try it and you'll
share with the world and then when
people like it and they pull it out of
you you just made a step function change
so the way to think about startups is
it's all about the stuff function change
and the ambition is what gives you the
motivation to keep going and you know I
mean I've been I've been in San
Francisco the variants of the valley
since 2008 so I've seen multiple Cycles
now I've seen friends uh you know
actually go from failure after failure
to building large companies and I'll
tell you every single time it looked
Bleak it looked like everything was just
and then it was just that one
Insight that one iteration that just
changed everything and it just like it's
it's really just a massive sub function
change up and then you just go from
there I think we're like you know
launching a rocket that's all it is uh
and you just gotta keep that ambition
you're launching a rocket and uh
you just keep going at it you know how
many how many failures that Elon have
three three yeah there you go
um just think about it like that thank
you so much for doing this I really
appreciate it everyone Angela CEO